It's important to keep an eye on Joe Biden's
policy proposals because on the one hand,
you have Donald Trump holding huge rallies
as if there's no pandemic, while insulting
Joe Biden saying Joe Biden is stupid, as he
did earlier this week.
And then, on the other hand, as a contract
contrast.
You have Joe Biden actually proposing some
pretty interesting policies.
And one such policy that Joe Biden recently
released is a 10 percent tax penalty on companies
that move operations overseas.
And then on the other side of that, a 10 percent
tax credit for companies that create jobs
in the United States.
I like the idea of Joe Biden rolling out more
economic policies, because if you're someone
who's voting on the big picture, right, you
you realize Donald Trump is a completely incompetent,
systemic threat to the United States and the
world.
And he's made the country a global laughingstock.
You may already be clear on I'm voting Biden
in November.
There are people who, for one reason or another,
need some more specific economic justifications
to vote for Joe Biden.
And one of those is that Joe Biden says he
will reverse some of the worst policies of
the Trump administration, which he believes
are loopholes that allow offshoring to take
place, despite Donald Trump claiming his entire
campaign entering his presidency, that he
would be and has been great for the American
worker and for American business.
It's impossible to ignore the reality that
Joe Biden on some of these issues is saying
he will achieve the exact same thing Donald
Trump promised to achieve when he was campaigning,
which is Joe Biden, much like Donald Trump
said in 2015, says he will revive American
manufacturing.
Joe Biden, much like Donald Trump campaigned
on in 2016, says he will create more American
jobs and bring some supply chains back to
the United States.
Of course, you will notice that the reason
Joe Biden is saying he will do those same
things is Donald Trump promised to do them,
but failed to do so.
And Joe Biden's new proposal will target offshore
profits now and then.
This is going to bigger picture get added
into his plan to require corporations to pay
at least a 15 percent minimum tax on domestic
profits.
As many of you know, even though we have a
corporate tax rate here in the United States
with no required minimum tax on corporations
the way individuals have.
There's something called the alternative minimum
tax for individuals, meaning you can't use
deductions and loopholes to get down to not
owing anything.
That in theory.
That's the point of the alternative minimum
tax.
Joe Biden is proposing something similar for
corporations.
On the other side of this is you've got on
one side a 10 percent tax for offshoring and
then you have a 10 percent made in America
tax credit, which you would qualify for if
you, as a business owner, revitalize a closed
or almost closed facility in the United States.
If you expand a facility, if you bring some
production back to the United States and there
will also be a 10 percent credit available
if you increase manufacturing wages, it has
to be based on pre corona virus has a baseline
up to 100 hundred thousand dollars.
This is super interesting.
Let me give you an example of how it works.
You could conceivably have an employee earning
50000 dollars and you could say, I'm going
to give them a raise to sixty thousand dollars
on that 10000 dollar raise.
Biden's proposal is the government will kick
you back 10 percent of it.
So you give a ten thousand dollar raise.
The government gives you a thousand dollar
tax credit.
So you give someone ten thousand dollars.
It only costs you nine.
That's very, very interesting.
And, you know, the macro economic impact needs
to be scored.
But conceptually, it's very interesting.
Now, I wonder how many of you are waiting
to see whether I will do this.
I would be a hypocrite if I didn't point this
out when Joe Biden says it, because I sure
as hell pointed it out when Donald Trump said
it.
All of the talk about bringing manufacturing
jobs back to the United States.
A lot of these jobs are not coming back.
Period.
It doesn't matter if Donald Trump is president.
It doesn't matter if Joe Biden is president.
And, you know, a 10 percent credit here, a
10 percent tax there.
It's not going to do it.
And that is because the United States made
the decision implicitly decades ago that we
are going in the direction of being more of
a service based economy, more of a creative
economy, and outsourcing manufacturing to
places where it's cheaper, like China.
That's the reality.
And that's a global reality that's bigger
than 10 percent tax here, 10 percent credit
there.
Now, that being said, if this incentive got
American companies to, for example, move a
call center back to the United States, that
is much more plausible.
And I would find super interesting four for
me, one of the biggest.
Service nightmares is when you're trying to
deal with something sensitive.
For example, banking, payroll, airline tickets,
Internet security and customer service centers
are located in other parts of the country,
which is fine other than when you're dealing
with people that do not speak English at a
certain level of proficiency.
That really affects customer service.
And when you look at Internet service providers,
that offshore call centers, when you look
at airlines and all of these others consistently,
it destroys the customer experience.
We've had recent Internet problems.
Our Internet service providers tech support
is in another part of the world run by mediocre
English speakers.
They're not bad people.
They're no worse than Americans.
But it is not a great customer service experience.
At one point, the payroll company we used
to have had customer service overseas.
It's not a great experience to be trying to
setup, you know, the proper tax deductions
for employees and to have someone where you
don't even know if their English level is
at a level of proficiency where they're getting
what you're trying to do.
If this idea gets call centers back in the
United States, that would be super interesting
and it would be really good for a lot of companies.
In any case, we're going to continue tracking
Joe Biden's proposals.
This is an interesting one.
Meanwhile, Donald Trump is doing rallies and
calling Joe Biden stupid.
You decide which approach you prefer.
I know which one I prefer.